I like this well the Kelty nyan who look
amazing I do think it's kind of weird
though that we're talking about fall
fashion because it's been 157 degrees in
Los Angeles all week right
but chunky sweater with weather it's
everything well got it I'm embracing it
I don't care if it's 100 degrees and I
had to up my style game at the CBS Radio
we can survive charity concerts so we
teamed up with marshals to help me find
the perfect look so every time I'm here
I'm always amazed by the surprising
selection and high quality of the items
I never know what I'm gonna find but I
know I'm gonna love it all right let's
go
[Music]
all right so how cute am I this is such
an easy everyday outfit
now all the grand names are here but
you're not gonna pay brand-name prices
how cute is this coat this is perfect
for date night this trench
I'm obsessed you're never taking it off
find a sequined dress throw a little
topper on a cute bag and you are ready
for every holiday party I love layering
patterns one of the greatest things to
do for fall you take a little blouse and
silky blouse and as a bright color
bright pattern and then you layer it
with your favorite sweatshirt it's easy
it's casual but super stylish so I ended
up finding so many things that I love
but at these great prices I can take
them all now I have to make a decision I
am officially concert-ready this is the
look I chose I'm feeling very rock and
roll and ready for the concert
Thanks Marshalls
you